if you think it's still having a
mortgage right now how about having 36
mortgages
for Sean a landlord in Hull a single
interest rate hike means 36 or eight
hikes our costs have increased from
about six thousand five hundred to
seventeen thousand five hundred in the
space of 14-month sites it's a massive
difference so we're going to have to put
rents we are putting rents up we're
having to put rent up uh reluctantly
with today's increase we're breaking
even on some Properties or even in a
deficit in minus it's um it's really bad
news
it's a useful reminder that higher
interest rates aren't just a big deal
for those with mortgages those costs
filter through the system and often get
passed on to renters too
but there was actually good news from
the bank today alongside the rate
increase it now believes Britain will
narrowly avoid falling into recession
this year back at the beginning of
February yeah we were really a bit on a
knife edge as to whether there would be
a recession certainly we thought the
economy would be quite stagnant I'm not
saying it's going to it's not Off to the
Races let's be clear but I'm a bit more
optimistic now but many economists warn
that the bank will have to do more to
clamp down on Rising prices I certainly
wouldn't
um rule out them going up towards five
percent
um but I think the MPC have done most of
the heavy lifting that they need to do
so they've raised interest rates from
nearly to zero to four and a quarter
percent now and maybe they need to go up
to perhaps closer to five percent but
the bank is walking a dangerous
tightrope now one of the bank of
England's main jobs is trying to keep
inflation under control it's supposed to
be hitting two percent but as you can
see it's way above that 10.4 percent in
February and that helps explain why it
is Raising interest rates 11 straight
increases up to four point two five
percent now but here's the issue the
higher that goes the more the risk of
financial instability and you have
problems in Banks leading to a dilemma
for the bank of England does it want to
clamp down on inflation or does it want
to keep markets calm
investors still think there'll be
another one or two rape risers to come
but with banks having collapsed on both
sides of the Atlantic
many are asking whether there are still
more financial time bombs yet to go off
at Conway Sky News